Avengers: Endgame co-director Joe Russo has
a few choice words for Oscar voters.
Critics are near-unanimous in their praise
of the film and Robert Downey, Jr.'s performance
as Tony Stark but if Russo were to have his
way, the Marvel Cinematic Universe's biggest
star would take home an Academy Award for
the flick, according to The Washington Post.
Heads up some spoilers for Avengers: Endgame
ahead.
During a stop in the nation's capital on a
promotional tour for the film late last week,
Russo didn't hold back about the contributions
his star made not only to Endgame, but to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and popular
culture in general.
He explained,
"His cumulative body of work from these movies
is staggering.
If you look at the work over just even the
last four [Marvel] films he's done, it's phenomenal…
He deserves an Oscar perhaps more than anyone
in the last 40 years because of the way that
he has motivated popular culture."
There have been a lot of great film performances
in the last 40 years, and Russo's making quite
a bold statement but he does have a point.
Downey kicked off the entire MCU with what
was seen at the time as an improbably brilliant
performance in 2008's Iron Man, and since
then, he has added layers of depth and complexity
to a character that could have been more one-note
in the hands of a lesser actor.
According to Cinemablend, his casting was
seen by industry analysts as a gamble when
it was announced in 2007.
"I am Iron Man"
In the decade leading up to his first triumphant
turn as Stark, Downey had struggled heavily
with alcohol abuse, a poor public image, and
a tendency to confuse and alienate those around
him all issues which had plagued Stark for
years in the pages of Marvel comics.
Now, Russo and his co-director brother Anthony
Russo believe Downey's work should be taken
into consideration by the Academy's voters.
Anthony said,
"He has a very involved process a more involved
process than any actor we've ever worked with.
He digs deeper, and he works harder than anybody.
[...] Downey really just goes the extra mile
for everything it's like everything he's doing
is something to his core."
Joe Russo also made the point that the Academy
seems to have an inherent bias against "popular"
movies in the modern era, compared to past
Oscar Best Picture winners like The Sound
of Music, The Godfather, and Rocky, to name
just a few.
He added,
"We're talking about some of the most popular
films ever made.
It feels like there's now a prejudice against
popular cinema.
In a way, that's somewhat sad."
Downey has been nominated for Oscars twice
before: once for the title role in the 1992
biopic Chaplin and again for his controversial
comedic turn in 2008's Tropic Thunder.
But he permeated the role of Tony Stark with
his own personality, and with Endgame, he
masterfully brought a close to an arc that
has taken over ten years to complete.
"Part of the journey is the end."
It seems almost inconceivable now, but when
Marvel Studios chose to lead off their cinematic
universe with Iron Man, the character was
so obscure that the choice left industry analysts
scratching their heads.
In the lead-up to its release, Marvel even
commissioned short animated films intended
to raise the character's public profile.
Today, the character has become a household
name, one of the most popular in all of mainstream
cinema and it almost certainly would never
have happened if Downey had not poured his
heart and soul into the character every time
he stepped in front of the cameras for Marvel.
Over the last decade-plus, Downey has delivered
an acting performance unlike any in film history
and for that, we agree that he deserves his
industry's highest honor.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Endgame
and the MCU are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.